hey what's up guys it's rob
and welcome to my tutorial for the epic
two-in-one
paper cup boomerang and helicopter most
people use their cups to have a drink
and throw it away so i thought is there
some way that we can get this cup so
that when you threw it away it actually
came back
well after a few cuts and folds the
paper cup becomes a fun two-in-one model
that not only spins down like a
helicopter but becomes an amazing
boomerang that comes back to you
it even has a ninja star on the back
that i thought would look really cool
when i designed it and of course
it's a great boomerang for doing trick
shots it not only works with a variety
of paper cups but you can also throw it
with your left and right hand
so try throwing two at the same time so
get ready to learn the all-new
paper cup boomerang and helicopter i'd
like to take a moment to thank my new
patrons ximena and adam it was fun
teaching you on zoom i showed them the
boomerang on my discord server and they
definitely wanted to learn it
if you want your chance to get a shout
out have your idea featured
access to my discord server or get
one-on-one help and more
head over to my patreon and support me
for a limited time i'm offering all new
patrons a 30-minute zoom lesson
you're going to need a paper cup and
some scissors while it can work without
tape
some cups can be thicker or have outside
layers like these making it harder to
fold
and it might require some tape just to
hold the flaps down plastic cups won't
work for the boomerang but can work for
the helicopter but not as well as paper
pure styrofoam won't work but these
paper coffee cups
with paper inside and soft foam exterior
will work
but might need tape because they don't
fold as well as regular paper
once you have the proper supplies let's
do it
we need to first take the cup and cut it
into eight equal sections like this
to start we're going to hold it on two
opposite sides and pull apart and
flatten it as best we can
and make two really sharp pinches on the
outside we're only folding the top of
the rim not the entire cup
we can take the scissors and cut the cup
directly up from the pinch in the rim
all the way to the base as straight as
we can then we could do the same on the
opposite side
cutting it all the way from the rim to
the base now we could take the two edges
of
each half and meet them together and
make a pinch directly in the middle of
the rim just like this
turn it around and do the same on the
other side meeting the two cut corners
or edges of the rim
holding them together rounding it and
giving it a pinch
now once again we can cut it directly on
that pinch
from the rim all the way to the base on
both sides
if it helps you can make a mark on the
rim and draw a line to help you make
nice straight cuts or sometimes the cup
has patterns you can use to guide you as
well
to ensure you're cutting all the way to
the bottom of the inside you could take
the scissors and place them on the
inside of the cup to see it going
all the way down to the base just like
this now we can cut the quarter sections
into eighths by once again
folding the rim in half like this and
making a pinch
do that for all four pieces trying to
ensure that they are folded exactly in
half
once you've made a pinch on all four of
the sections hold them and
just like before cut them in half trying
to divide them evenly down the middle of
the section
so all eight pieces are about the same
width
take your time and try to cut as
straight and vertically as you can
when you're finished it should look like
this and just make sure you cut
all the way to the base on the inside of
the cup
we're going to look for the section that
has the joint or lip in it and fold that
down
first we're going to fold it down so
that it is flush
completely with the base it should fold
down easily and you shouldn't hear any
rips if you did cut all the way to the
bottom of the cup
then we're going to skip every other
section and fold them down so that it's
flat with the base
continue until you have folded down four
cup sections
and it should look just like this
now we could set it down on the table
and flatten the four
sections which we just folded down i'm
just going to make an
x on the sections we folded down with a
marker
and once we've done that at this point
this is the helicopter configuration and
if you flip it over and spin it
it'll float down as a helicopter which
i'll show a bit later
[Music]
at this point we're going to fold down
all of the sections here
the sections we mark with the x are
going to be the boomerang blades while
the others are going to be interlocked
like a ninja star
to create a flap or airfoil on each
blade just like we did with the other
sections
fold down the last four sections and
flatten them out so they are even with
the base
if you're having difficulty doing this
make sure you cut far enough
set it down on the table and make sure
everything's nice and flat
before you try to make the boomerang
inspect it to make sure the blades are
relatively equal flat and neat
not like this if it does you may want to
toss it and try it again
now we can mark the other sections one
to four in a
clockwise direction then we can cut off
the very tip of the rim
on only those numbered sections then
we're going to take the two
opposite sections in this case one and
three and fold them
inwards with the bottom section folded
up on the left
and the top section folded down on the
right the inside edges should not be
overlapped but touching
then we could turn it and do the same
with sections two and four
folding them inwards the same exact way
once we folded them in we could press
down firmly
this is the same way that they will be
arranged when they are interlocked
now we can open the numbered sections we
just folded inwards
we're going to now interlock them in a
clockwise direction
starting with one and then moving to two
three and so forth we're gonna first
fold down one so that the left side of
it is on the edge of the cup base
then we're going to fold two on top of
it and then
three down on top of two
now the last one four is going to go on
top of three
and underneath one so we're going to
slide one out from underneath two
just like this and create a little
pocket or an opening like a little
bridge
then we could round four off and curve
it
a little bit at the end and push it
through the opening
underneath one once it's tucked under
you can grab it on the other side
and pull it all the way through to make
sure the sections are interlocked snugly
we're just going to pull
or tug on the two opposite sections to
ensure that they're tucked in all the
way
and secure and just press down when
we've done that
it should look something just like this
now you'll see when we interlock the
sections on the back it created an
overhang here on the other side of the
boomerang blades
you should notice that the flaps will be
counterclockwise or on the left side of
the blade
when they're facing directly upwards
these will create an
airfoil flap which we need to fold down
along the edge of the boomerang blade
so fold down all the way so that it's
flush with the top of the blade
and make a nice sharp crease and we will
do that now for the remaining three
airfoil flaps
fold down along the top of the blade and
crease sharply
finally complete the last one by folding
it down and creasing and it should look
something like this
if you find that the airfoils pop out or
stick up you can try
taping them down at the very center here
just wrap the lower third with tape to
keep it flat
and secure
[Music]
throw the helicopter just make sure that
the four propellers are bent upwards
like this
and the other ones are facing down and
haven't been folded yet
then all you need to do is just throw it
from a height and give it a spin
spin it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so to throw the boomerang i'm going to
take it like this
and you can take it in your right hand
like this
and hold it with your two fingers on top
and your
fit your thumb right on the airfoil here
just like that and kind of
rest it on the rest of your fingers and
i'm just going to flick my wrist out
it's going to snap my wrist like that
so take it and just snap your wrist out
like that
you can also take it in your hand in one
of the arms and flick it this way
and you can use your left hand even and
just do the same kind of thing
and it basically works with all these
different cups
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i hope you guys liked the video for the
paper cup boomerang and the helicopter
if you did be sure to give it a thumbs
up
and smash that like button down below
and also don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell if you
haven't already since i'm new to patreon
and i'd like to connect with more fans
since i've had a lot of fun doing the
private zoom lessons i'm gonna make it
for the next two months no matter what
two you join
i will give you a zoom lesson a 30
minute lesson
on whatever you'd like so be sure to
check out my patreon to support me
also leave me a comment down below let
me know what you'd like to see next more
boomerangs rubik's cubes or if you want
to see this cool duct tape hat that i
made
let me know and i will see you guys soon